[Music]  you're known to do your own stunts on  nikita did you get injured recently um i  i  did a bunch of things i cracked a shin i  brought i broke some fingers i burned my  boobs i how did you burn your boobs  sorry to go right to that one  kind of the obvious place to go you  didn't see the flaming bra episode  revenge of the flaming bra  how did that happen i just i was just  shooting a gun and i was running and i  was running so fast that the the the hot  shells fell into my  jacket oh they you're running shooting  shots and the hot shells are coming out  and they go into your cleavage i was  running down a hill though and so as i  was running down i was shooting and the  trajec i was running so fast that i i  they fell  at the perfect time and went straight  down my yeah into my bra and so what how  did did you go to the hospital well no  everyone on set was a medic that day  every guy  hundreds of miles